help me out with I you know I had the
advantage in Cuba and in Mexico as I
speak some Spanish than palatable
Spanish and I understand when when
people are speaking to me what they're
saying
for instance you know I've known some
French over the years but French Creole
sinusitis it's a little bit of the
Creole that you need just socked passe
is that per se and then the answer to
that is nob Boulet well you got asking
sak pase is like what's up as I say and
you and the answer is not bit doubleday
now believe it I'm fine I'm what if I'm
not good what if I'm not still saying
novel a and then I go
[Laughter]
what about any advice on there's
different music there's different
tradition you know it kind of things you
has amazing music we've got a great
music scene important friends with a lot
of great bands really great nightlife
you know there's tons of good
restaurants and really good like
sidewalk stalls you know Anthony
Bourdain it's a bit and champagne
guy last time I saw I was there over
there chef named Jose Andres who's a one
of the great chefs of America has done
incredible work in Puerto Rico feeding
people and we were just went to like
bunch of sidewalk stalls and ate there
and I'm always I'd like I'm very
cautious about what I eat I had the same
thing every day for every meal because I
really I just don't care about food what
do you have like a fruit roll-up you're
like a child my son has the same thing
out of a [ __ ] what do you hate what do
you have a nice box and I like what it
what a picture I don't go to the beach I
don't care about food yeah Wow what is
it what is really your come on now that
we're on it what is your lunch every day
depending for like three months and I'll
get so sick of it I can't eat it for
another six but what might that be give
me an example like as a kid I would eat
a big potato for every meal for a long
time and then I would switch to like
spaghetti for every meal so now now what
I'm eating I'm trying to eat healthy so
I'm eating like a salad for every
right and then I get sick it's so sick
but I never want to see Sal again and
then I'll switch to like have you ever
been to Boston Market and they have the
turkey meal it's like a Thanksgiving
meal are you getting paid for this no
I'm not they had this meal and it's like
Thanksgiving so I have that for every
meal okay yeah it's sounding sad a lot
of people look up like you're the warden
of your own prison yeah it's consistency
and otherwise orderly existence yes yes
whatever you liked you like to go and
and and you you will try this this
different food and yes because I really
want to try the Creole food so they have
to tell you you know I'm not a hard
drinking man right I like to put that
the rock that's very wrong there I love
rock I loves me wrong and and I'm really
looking forward to having a lot of wrong
yes they're probably great rum drinks
yeah it's like Bettencourt rum is like
the legendary in Haiti and yeah yeah you
go to the factory probably that's one of
the things that I love about being out
in the field too is I get to drink but
do you really there's no alcohol in this
setting right Andy Andy will tell you oh
there's no nobody's looked everywhere
there's nothing but when you go out on
the field people are always you're done
taping and there's always a bar you're
in different parts of the world with a
bar right there and you're like them but
as I see all our cameramen are
alcoholics right guys
yeah I wish that was a joke cameraman
don't go to sleep when we're in these
other countries and then we lose track
of them one in particular I'm not gonna
name them but it's James he disappears
for a while and then he comes back the
next morning and he's still holding his
camera everything but there's blood
coming out of his eyes he's got that
kind of hangover where it's like I think
he died
you